Спікерка Палати представників Конгресу США Ненсі Пелосі прилетіла до Тайваню.
Її візит супроводжувався пильною увагою з усього світу.
Не в останню чергу через позицію Пекіна,
який був наполегливо проти.
"Не грайте з вогнем" - таким було послання голови КНР Сі Цзіньпіна
своєму американському колезі Джо Байдену
в його останніх зверненнях.
Китай стверджує, що США небезпечно близькі до того, щоб перетнути червону лінію щодо Тайваню.
Напередодні візиту Пелосі у китайських соцмережах взагалі навіть закликали збити її літак.
Однак візит пройшов успішно.
Думки самих тайванців щодо його доцільності розділилися.
Щодо заяв Китаю, то насправді так було завжди.
Тож ми дивимося на це зі спокійною душею і не надто боїмося.
Тайваню важко йти своїм шляхом, тому що ми настільки непомітні,
що нічого не можемо вдіяти. Отже, цей візит нічого не означає,
якщо чесно, це просто словесна суперечка.
Чим викликана категорична позиція Китаю в ефірі
Deutsche Welle розповіла заступниця директора Центру тайванських досліджень Лондонського університету Бі-Ю Чанг.
За словами експертки, Пекін особливо гостро реагує
саме на нинішній візит Ненсі Пелосі через внутрішньополітичні амбіції Сі Цзіньпіна.
Головна причина - це 20 Загальнокитайський з'їзд Комуністичної партії Китаю.
Сі Цзіньпін хоче отримати місце голови ЦК партії.
Цю посаду ніхто після Мао Цзедуна не обіймав.
І зараз якраз той час, коли і Комуністична партія Китаю,
і Сі Цзіньпін мають діяти жорстко,
а візит Пелосі підриває його авторитет та стабільність.
Пекін вважає Тайвань територією КНР, яку тимчасово окупували політичні спадкоємці тих,
хто програв громадянську війну в Китаї в 1949 році.
З того часу Тайвань тримає автономію.
На острові проводять регулярні військові та цивільні навчання
для підготовки до можливого китайського вторгнення.
Західні військові експерти прогнозують - військова конфронтація Китаю та Тайваню неминуча.
Про це DW розповів член комітету Бундестагу
з оборони та голова Німецько-тайванської
асоціації Маркус Фабер.
Я стурбований тим, що військові сутички можуть
відбутися у найближчі п'ять-вісім років.
Я був у Вашингтоні минулого листопада. І там були стурбовані,
що станеться військовий конфлікт між путінською
Росією та Україною цієї зими.
І водночас говорили, що вони стурбовані можливим військовим конфліктом
між Китаєм та Тайванем у найближчі 8 років.
За словами Фабера, військове вирішення конфлікту зачепить
не лише країни регіону, але й США, Корею та Японію.
Китай довів за останні кілька років, що він не хоче розвивати демократичні інститути
і не хоче захищати ліберальні цінності,
не хоче визнавати свободу слова.
Ми спостерігаємо це у багатьох регіонах, і в Гонконгу, і Сичуані.
Дедалі більше випадків, коли Китай влаштовує репресії
щодо власних громадян, а також загрожує іншим країнам.
Неоднозначну стратегію США щодо Тайваню описала
в інтерв'ю DW глава стокгольмсько-китайського форуму Марейке Ольберг.
Якщо подивитися на позицію США, то Вашингтон демонструє наступну стратегію стримування:
з одного боку США не кажуть, що неодмінно втрутяться у разі вторгнення у Тайвань,
з іншого - і не стверджують протилежного.
Залишається сподіватися, що ця стратегія
стримає Китай від атаки на острів.
Але будь-які спекуляції на цю тему рівносильні ворожінню на кавовій гущі.
Нагадаємо, що у травні Байден порушив багаторічну політику США,
пообіцявши Тайваню військову підтримку,
якщо Китай спробує вторгнутися.
Репортер: "Чи готові ви втрутитися у військовому плані для захисту Тайваню, якщо до цього дійде?"
Байден: "Так".
Репортер: "Ви?"
Байден: "Це зобов'язання, яке ми взяли на себе".
Вашингтон вважає, що Пекін порушує статус-кво.
За останній рік Сі Цзіньпін провокував Тайвань вторгненнями
в повітряний простір острова і закликав покласти край тайванському самоврядуванню.